hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein ganz schnelles rezept
denn ich werde tiramisu kugeln machen
tiramisu mag ich als dessert wirklich
sehr gerne tiramisu kogel finde ich
sogar noch etwas praktischer damals sie
dann ganz leicht aus der hand essen kann
und ich mache das immer ganz gerne wenn
ich zum beispiel mal einen tag übrig
habe
das habe ich heute aber man kann sie zum
beispiel auch mit löffelbiskuits machen
also muss jetzt nicht extra einen teig
dafür backen
die zutaten sind wirklich total
überschaubaren ich zeig dir euch mal
kurz ich hab hier 250 gramm mascarpone
einen espresso etwas vanille extrakt
habe ich bereits einen kuchenteig wie
gesagt da ist ganz neutral und ich habe
hier noch ein paar mandelsplitter
eigentlich sind keine mandelsplitter
sonne gehackte mandeln
die könnt ihr gerne mit dazu geben wenn
ihr gerne etwas krampfig mit in diesem
pralinen haben wollt oder elaste weg die
zutaten also ich hab zweites rezept so
und habt euch das auch aufgeschrieben
auf meinem blog
aber im prinzip braucht ihr da kein
rezept dazu denn ihr nehmt jetzt einfach
den kuchenteig oder in dem teufel
biscuit ist egal wie unter bröselt jetzt
erst mal und bei löffelbiskuits würde
ich das jetzt so machen dass er soeben
mit dem nudelholz zum beispiel
zerkleinert in einem gefrierbeutel ich
schreibe ich aber in meinem blog
natürlich auch die zutaten für den
kuchenteig auf das war ein lockerer
kuchenteig den ich gerne für motiv
torten benutze jetzt nehme ich den
espresso das ist bereits etwas abgekühlt
den g sich jetzt darüber
und wer möchte kann hier zum beispiel
auch etwas amaretto mit dazu geben was
er natürlich auch bei tiramisu immer mit
dabei ist also wenn man's alkoholisch
mag wenig lässt uns weg und statt dessen
kann man zum beispiel auch etwas mandl
sirup oder mandeln mit tamandl aroma
nehmen
bei mir kommt es noch etwas weil extrakt
mit rein wobei es auch beim teig mit
dabei habe ganz viele studien und ella
guck mir zu und darf ein bisschen hier
in der küche rumalbern und jetzt kommt
die mascarpone mit dazu und je nachdem
wie fest jetzt gleich licher teig mit
oder wie flüssig könnt ihr dann entweder
ein weitaus mehr mascarpone oder
flüssigkeit also espresso nehmen oder
nehmen noch ein bisschen mehr teig oder
löffelbiskuits das vermischte jetzt
alles schön miteinander
ich habe es bei mir noch etwas
kuchenteig mit dazu gegeben
und an dieser stelle müsste jetzt
einfach mal die masse probieren
abschmecken
wenn sie euch nicht süß genug jetzt
könnt ihr zum beispiel noch etwas
puderzucker mit dazugeben und ich gebe
jetzt für den crash noch ein paar
gehackte mandeln mit reimen jetzt
verrichte maßnahme noch mal und lasse
dann wird was zehn minuten ziehen
hier setze ich hier einen deckel drauf
und stellst dann für zehn minuten in den
kühlschrank
die masse sitzt durch gekühlt werde ich
welchen daraus formen
ich nehme da am liebsten einen kleinen
aktionäre dann habe ich nämlich immer
die gleiche größe aber esslöffel geht
zum beispiel auf dem tier direkt in die
hand und hier habe ich noch einen teller
mit etwas kakaopulver und das ist jetzt
ganz normaler back cacau also nichts
gesüßt und dieser ganz normal cargo mit
dem ich eben auch immer backe
da kommen die ich rein und mache jetzt
immer mehrere gleichzeitig dann geht es
nämlich etwas schneller
wenn sich der teller dann gefühlt habe
schüttle ich den teller so ein bisschen
hin und her und um mandl die bällchen
dann komplett mit dem kakaopulver
jetzt können dass sie entweder auf einem
teller setzen oder ihr könnt diese
kleine macht förmchen nehmen die habe
ich das in summe fünf ampeln für mini
muffins und da setzt sich die jetzt mit
rein denn man kann sie dann eben auch
super aus der hand essen ohne dass man
sich eben ständig dreckig macht
bevor man die therapie ist so kugeln
jetzt essen kann sollte man sie vorne
über kühlen denn ganz durch gekühlt
schmecken sie am besten ich stelle sie
jetzt für etwa eine stunde in den
kühlschrank
ihr könnt sie aber auch zum beispiel am
morgen zu bereit und abends essen oder
sogar am tag vorher die tiramisu kugeln
sind jetzt gut durch kühlt die waren
jetzt für eine stunde im kühlschrank
aber man kann die auch wie gesagt super
vorbereiten und der murat darf jetzt
auch probieren machst du probieren
auflief ich habe ja auch im frischen
espresso gemacht bitteschön und die
kamera ist super aus der hand essen also
man sollte sie auch wirklich als
fingerfood anbieten also für alle
zuschauer im fernsehen über youtube
reisten frischer espresso heißt der
deutschen kalt hatte eigentlich habe ich
ihnen das foto gemacht aber es noch
schön warm
nein das ist dieser doppel becher
er fühlt sich jetzt nur kalt an aber
erst noch einmal gesehen ist es immer
der ist kalt und dann halt was sich die
zunge zu gut war aber der zweck ist das
im super trinken kann es nicht heißt
aber auch nicht jetzt darfst du gerne
diese kugeln probieren genau meinst du
kannst nix wissen und die eignen sich
zum beispiel auch super gerade jetzt zur
ramadan zeit weil man die eben
vorbereiten kann
und es ist halt auch was kleines also
nach dem essen kann man dann so zwei
drei küken an den essen so richtig
premier beim beim fasten tut mir ja
immer mit einer dattel fastenbrechen
anfängt anfang anfangen und kann man es
auch mit dem risiko ja kein schmarrn
murat bedrängt mit ihrer musik kugel
meine arbeitskollegen nämlich das
problem alle warten jetzt schon geld
nicht in den winkel halten
ich probiere jetzt sollen alle warten
darauf ist der murat probiert mal im
innern sind sehr hell außen schön dunkel
und man kann sie natürlich auch ab wann
lässt mich noch ein problem das nicht
gefallen naja du besonders einmal
abweisen
das war's jetzt ich zeige das innere das
muss schon sagen
schluck einfach ist ich meinte sich der
vorteil dass er eben klein genug sind
das muss mit einem haps verschlingen
kann jetzt aber jetzt kann man zeigen
hier richtig sie ein aus marzipan kugel
ja schmeckt aber nach therapie so
nachwuchs nicht zu süß folter das finde
ich auch super und ich mag halt dieses
was ich mag dieses kakaopulver außen
herum weniges jetzt aber zum beispiel
nicht mögen und gerne zum beispiel
zitronenkuchen machen wollt geht ihr
einfach geriebene zitronenschale mit
rein und dann vielleicht in kokons
velsen cacau also da gibt es ganz viele
abwandlungen vielleicht können wir noch
eine davon mal machen oder mögt dann
genau und falls ihr die mama wollte
jedoch sallys - docdata stets noch mal
ganz genau und ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß nachmachen und bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss und halt durch beim
passen da ist so viel geredet ich glaube
deine sprecher anteilig länger als ein
komplettes video ja ich musste auch nie
zeigen es noch darin ok-chef macht's gut